used to be a guy who used to believe you
know we go in there we kick some ass
blah blah blah I don't believe that
anymore I think we are involved in
everybody's business I think the America
that I thought we were overseas I'm not
sure that I mean you can't torture
people say we're not going to torture a
ghost plane you to Egypt and expect the
Egyptians to think we're the beacon of
Liberty so we've destroyed all of that
um this Ukraine thing is an absolute
nightmare uh I mean you could be looking
of end of days kind of stuff with Iran
and uh Israel I don't want to be
involved in any of these things uh and
Nikki is saying we got to go in there
and we got to take out you know Vladimir
Putin and and and then what then who
replaces him you know that's not our
business and